you've said that
um with this metaphor analogy that
theory of everything is a big mountain
and
you have a sense that
however far we're up the mountain
that the the wolfram physics
model a view
of the universe is at least the right
mountain we're the right mountain
yes without the question so i'm which
aspect of it is the right mountain so
for example i mean so there's so many
aspects to just
the way of the wolfram physics project
the way it approaches the world
that's um that's clean crisp
and uh unique and powerful so
you know there's a there's discrete
nature to it there's a
hypergraph there's a computational
nature
there's a generative aspect you start
from nothing you generate everything
which do you think the actual model is
actually a really good one
or do you think this general principle
of from simplicity generating complexity
is the right
like what aspect of the mountain yeah
right i mean i i think that the
the kind of the meta idea about using
simple computational systems
to do things that's you know that's the
ultimate
big paradigm that is you know
sort of super important the details of
the particular model
are very nice and clean and allow one to
actually understand what's going on
they are not unique and in fact we know
that we know that there's a
there's a large number of different ways
to describe essentially the same thing
i mean i can describe things in terms of
hypergraphs i can describe them in terms
of higher category theory
i can describe them in a bunch of
different ways they are in some sense
all the same thing
but our sort of story about what's going
on and the kind of
kind of cultural mathematical resonances
are a bit different
i mean i think it's it's it's perhaps
worth sort of saying a little bit about
kind of the the you know foundational
ideas of of
uh of uh you know these of these models
and things
great so can you maybe uh can we like
rewind we've talked about a little bit
but can you say like what the central
idea is of the wolfram physics project
right so so the question is we're
interested in finding
a sort of simple computational rule that
describes our whole universe
can we just pause on that it's just so
beautiful that's such a beautiful
that's such a beautiful idea that we can
generate our universe
from from uh from a data structure
a simple structure simple set of rules
and we can generate our entire universe
yes that's awe-inspiring
right but but so so you know the
question is
how do you actualize that what might
this rule be like
and so one thing you quickly realize is
if you're going to pack
everything about our universe into this
tiny rule
not much that we are familiar with in
our universe will be obvious in that
rule
so you don't get to fit all these
parameters of the universe all these
features of you know this is how space
works this is our timer et cetera et
cetera et cetera
you don't get to fit that all it all has
to be sort of packed in to this
this thing something much smaller much
more basic much lower level machine code
so to speak
than that and all the stuff that we're
familiar with has to kind of emerge
from the operation so the rule in itself
because of the
computational reducibility is not going
to tell you the story
it's not going to give you the answer to
uh
it's not going to let you predict what
you're going to have for lunch tomorrow
right it's not going to let you predict
basically anything about your life about
the universe
right but and you're not going to be
able to see in that rule
oh there's the three for the number of
dimensions of space and so on right
that's not going to be so space time is
not going to be obviously
right so the question is then what what
is the universe made of
that's that's a it's a basic question
and we've had some assumptions about
what the universe is made of for the
last few thousand years
that i think in some cases i just turned
out not to be right
and you know the most important
assumption is that space
is a continuous thing that is that
you can if you say let's pick a point
in space we're going to do geometry
we're going to pick a point we can pick
a point
absolutely anywhere in space precise
numbers
we can specify of where that point is in
fact you know euclid who kind of
wrote down the original kind of
axiomatization of geometry
back in 300 bc or so um you know his
his very first definition he says a
point is that which has no part
a point is this is this you know uh
this indivisible you know infinitesimal
thing
okay so we might have said that about
material objects we might have said that
about water for example
we might have said water is a continuous
thing that we can just
uh you know pick any point we want in in
some water
but actually we know it isn't true we
know that water is made of molecules
that are discrete and so the question
one fundamental question is what is
space made of
and so one of the things that's sort of
a starting point for
what i've done is to think of space as a
discrete thing
to think of there being sort of atoms of
space just as there are atoms of
material things although very different
kinds of atoms
and by the way i mean this idea you know
there were
ancient greek philosophers who had this
idea there were you know einstein
actually thought this is probably how
things would work out i mean he said
you know repeatedly he thought this is
where it would work out we don't have
the mathematical tools
in our time which was 1940s 1950s and so
on
to explore this like the way he thought
you mean that there is something
very very small and discreet
that's underlying space space yes
and that means that so you know the
mathematical theory
mathematical theories in physics assume
that space
can be described just as a continuous
thing you can just pick
coordinates and the coordinates can have
any values and that's
how you define space space is this just
sort of background
uh sort of theater on which the universe
operates
but can we draw a distinction between
space as a thing that could be described
by
uh three values coordinates
and how you're are you are you using the
word space more generally when you say
no i'm just talking about what we spaces
in in the universe so you think this
3d aspect of it is fundamental no i
don't think that 3d is
fundamental at all actually i think that
the what's the
the thing that has been assumed is that
space is this
continuous thing where you can just
describe it by let's say three numbers
for instance
but most important thing about that is
that you can describe it by precise
numbers
because you can pick any point in space
and you can talk about motions any
infinitesimal motion in space
and that's what continuous means that's
what continuous means that's what you
know newton invented calculus to
describe these kind of continuous small
variations and so on
that was that's kind of a fundamental
idea from euclid on
that's been a fundamental idea about
space and
so right or wrong uh it's not right
it's not right it's it's it's it's right
at the level of our experience
most of the time it's not right at the
level of the machine code so to speak
and so machine code yeah of the
simulation that's right that's right the
the very lowest level of the fabric of
the universe
at least under the the the wolfram
physics model
is your senses is discrete right so so
now
what does that mean so it means what
what is space
then so in in our models
the basic idea is you say there are
these
sort of atoms of space they're these
points that represent
you know represent places in space but
they're just discrete points
and the only thing we know about them is
how they're connected to each other
we don't know where they are they don't
have coordinates we don't get to say
this is a position such and such
it's just here's a big bag of points
like in our universe there might be 10
to the 100 of these points
and all we know is this point is
connected to this other point so it's
like
you know all we have is the friend
network so to speak we don't we don't
have
you know people's you know physical
addresses all we have is the friend
network of these points
yeah the underlying nature of reality is
kind of like a facebook uh
we don't know their location but we have
the friends yeah yeah right we we know
which point
is connected to which other points and
and that's all we know
and so you might say well how on earth
can you get something which is
like our experience of of you know what
seems like continuous space well the
answer is
by the time you have 10 to the 100 of
these things there
those connections can work in such a way
that
on a large scale it will seem to be like
continuous space
in let's say three dimensions or some
other number of dimensions or 2.6
dimensions or whatever else
because they're much much much much
larger so like the
uh the number of relationships here
we're talking about is just a humongous
amount so
the the kind of thing you're talking
about is very very very small relative
to our experience of daily life right so
i mean you know we don't know exactly
the size but maybe
maybe uh uh 10 to the minus
uh maybe around 10 to the minus 100
meters so
you know the size of to give a
comparison the size of a of a proton is
10 to the minus 15 meters
and so this is something incredibly tiny
compared to that
um and and the idea that from that would
emerge
the experience of continuous space
is mind-blowing well what's your
intuition why
that's possible like first of all i mean
we'll get in
into it but i don't know if we will
through
the medium of conversation but the
construct of hypergraphs is just
beautiful right
let's tell your automator beautiful
we'll talk about it but right but
this thing about you know continuity
arising from discrete
systems is in today's world is actually
not so surprising i mean you know your
average computer screen right
every computer screen is made of
discrete pixels yet we have the
you know we have the idea that we're
seeing these continuous pictures
i mean it's you know the fact that on a
large scale continuity can arise
from lots of discrete elements this is
at some level
unsurprising now like but the pixels
have a very definitive structure
of neighbors on a computer screen
right there is no concept of spatial
of space inherent in the
underlying fabric of reality right right
right so so the
the point is but there are cases where
there are so for example let's just
imagine
you have a square grid okay and at every
point on the grid
you have one of these atoms of space and
it's connected to four other
four other atoms of space on the you
know north northeast southwest
corners right um there you have
something where if you zoom out
from that it's like a computer screen
yeah so the relationship
creates the the spatial like the
relationship
creates a constraint which then
[Music]
in an emergent sense creates a
like yeah like a sp uh
basically a spatial coordinate yeah that
thing yeah right even though
the individual point doesn't have a
special even though the individual point
doesn't know anything it just knows what
it's you know what its neighbors are
they on a large scale it can be
described by saying oh it looks like
it's a you know this grid zoomed out
grid you can say well you can describe
these different points by saying they
have certain positions coordinates etc
now in the in the sort of real setup
it's more complicated than that isn't
just a square grid or something
it's something much more dynamic and
complicated which
we'll talk about
you